عدد القتلى آخذ في الارتفاع من كلا الجانبين،
حيث تأكد مقتل أكثر من 700 شخص
في إسرائيل، وقتل ما يقرب من 500 فلسطيني، وتشير
تقديرات الأمم المتحدة إلى أن أكثر من 123 ألف
فلسطيني قد نزحوا بالفعل
منذ بدء القتال يوم السبت،
وينضم إلينا الآن محلل شؤون
الشرق الأوسط الفلسطيني الأمريكي عمر بدار.  أه عمر
أقدر وقتك للبدء بالتوقيت
أعتقد أن السؤال الكبير كان هو
المفاجأة وكيف حدث هذا
وكيف أخذت إسرائيل على حين غرة ولكن
ما هو شعورك فيما يتعلق بالتوقيت
لماذا حدث ذلك الآن
أم أعتقد  التوقيت
عشوائي بطبيعته لأنه بخلاف ذلك لن يكون
هجومًا مفاجئًا ناجحًا وأريد فقط
أن أذكر أنه من الواضح أن ما
رأيناه منه
كان مروعًا للغاية، لقد كنت
أستمع إلى ضيوفك السابقين الذين
أتحدث عن عدم تمكني من
العثور على أطفالهم وهذا أمر
مفجع للغاية وهو أب لطفلين
صغيرين ولا أستطيع أن أتخيل كيف
سأشعر إذا تم اختطافهم ولم أكن
أعرف مكانهم ولكن
الفضيحة الحقيقية هنا هي أن هذا  إنه أمر
مروع بقدر ما
يمكن التنبؤ به ويمكن منعه، ويتحدث الكثير من الناس
عن هذا باعتباره
فشلًا استخباراتيًا، لكنني أعتقد أن هناك
فشلًا جوهريًا أكبر بكثير في المنطق السليم وهو أنه
يمكنك وضع ملايين الفلسطينيين
تحت احتلال عسكري لأجل غير مسمى
ونظام  الفصل العنصري كما تعترف به
كل منظمة حقوق الإنسان الكبرى في
العالم، حيث ترتكب إسرائيل جرائم حرب يومية
ضد الفلسطينيين في كل مكان، وسرقة
الأراضي، وعدم إمكانية الوصول إلى المياه،
وإلقاء القنابل بشكل عشوائي على
المناطق المدنية، والاعتقاد بأن هذا
الوضع لن
يؤدي في النهاية إلى  إن الانفجار أمر
جنوني تمامًا، وهذا أمر
متوقع تمامًا، ومن الواضح
أننا كنا نتجه نحو
كارثة من هذا النوع في نهاية المطاف،
والآن كل هذا الاتجاه نحو
المزيد من النزعة العسكرية والمزيد من العنف
من الواضح أنه لن يؤدي إلى
أي شيء أفضل لأن هذا هو بالضبط
المسار الذي  أوصلتنا إلى هنا، أعتقد أن هذا
صحيح تمامًا، فنحن بحاجة إلى
حل حقيقي وهادف
للظلم الكامن الذي يدفع هذا العنف،
وهذا يعني أن الفلسطينيين
سيعيشون متحررين من السيطرة والاحتلال الإسرائيليين،
عمر الذي سمعته للتو من
ميكال وديفيد فوق البحث  في
محاولة يائسة لابنهم البالغ من العمر 20 عامًا،
فهم واحد من بين 100
رهينة على الأقل محتجزين في هذه اللحظة. هذا
ما قاله المتحدث باسم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
المقدم HEC
بين عشية وضحاها، "نحن لا نركز هجماتنا على
النساء والأطفال
أم نحن"  سنبذل كل ما في وسعنا
لتقليل الأضرار الجانبية ولكن مرة أخرى نحن
في حالة حرب مع
كاماس وللأسف، من المحزن أنه
قد يكون هناك أشخاص متورطون في
القتل، وهذا لن يكون مقصودًا،
وللأسف فقد رسخت حماس
نفسها بطريقة ساخرة داخل المدنيين  لقد
قلتم للسكان أن هذا
الصراع لا يمكن حله عسكريًا، كيف
ترون هذه النهاية إلى أين ترون
هذا الأمر؟
أعني انظروا، هناك كل هذه
التصريحات حول الحاجة إلى أنهم
سيفعلون كل ما في وسعهم
لتجنب وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين.  ومن الجدير
التأكيد هنا على أن
إسرائيل قصفت غزة عدة مرات من
قبل، وتقول هيومن رايتس ووتش ومنظمة
العفو الدولية وحتى
منظمات حقوق الإنسان الإسرائيلية مثل بيتم
إن هذا ليس سلوك إسرائيل على الإطلاق،
ولا يوجد جهد لتقليل
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين إلى أدنى حد ممكن.
هناك قصف عشوائي جماعي
للمناطق المدنية، وبصراحة نحن
نشاهد ذلك يتكشف الآن أيضًا،
فالسياسة هي في الأساس
معاقبة جميع السكان الفلسطينيين
بقطع الكهرباء عن غزة بأكملها،
ومنع أي شخص في غزة من الدخول
والخروج من هذا  هو عمل من أعمال
العقاب الجماعي، وهذا هو بالضبط
المسار الذي لا نسير فيه، وأعتقد أن
ما سنراه هو موت أكبر بكثير،
سيغطي
قطاع غزة بأكمله، وفي النهاية
سيبقى الفلسطينيون
السكان الأسرى والخاضعون
لحصار غير قانوني كما تعترف به الأمم المتحدة
ونحن نجهز أنفسنا لجولة
أخرى من هذا في
المستقبل، ما نحتاجه الآن هو أن
يجتمع المجتمع الدولي
ويبدأ التعامل مع هذه القضية بجدية  إن
إدراك أن هذه السياسة المتمثلة في منح
إسرائيل العربة البيضاء للتصرف كما
تريد تجاه الفلسطينيين ليست
طريقة لتحقيق سلام طويل الأمد فعليًا،
فلا يمكنك الاستمرار في فعل
الشيء نفسه مرارًا وتكرارًا وتوقع
نتيجة مختلفة، الشيء الوحيد الذي  إن ما
لم تتم تجربته حتى الآن هو السماح
للفلسطينيين بالتحرر من
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي والدكتاتورية العسكرية،
وحتى نبدأ في أخذ
المظالم الفلسطينية على محمل الجد حتى تبدأ إسرائيل في
رؤية الفلسطينيين كبشر متساوين
يستحقون نفس
حقوق الإنسان واللياقة والكرامة
التي يتمتع بها الإسرائيليون.  استمتع، أخشى أننا
سنظل عالقين في هذا الوضع لفترة
طويلة جدًا، شكرًا لك عمر بدر
على انضمامك إلينا هذا الصباح